hello and welcome to this video
planes are also there also 78 okay
no no room and people are still
surprised by this Lauren Bishop g4 I
recommend its 92 there for white and my
in my book a move that has not yet been
caught on sorry for drinking was feels a
little bit impolite during recording and
but I had some spicier food is even and
Wow I really have to get some water into
my system
so if he goes bishop to age form is g5
the good Melissa
it's an interesting question
Bishop g3 I take and yes to take with
the F pawn it's not not the end of the
world probably no I'm not sure about it
okay now I have to reckon with g4 though
mm okay
it's a bit of a pain running
it's not what I wanted
no why does definitely a little bit
better him okay okay come on it should
be okay really now he does not have that
many pieces that still can attack me the
night is very reasonable defender like
26 rupee five yeah no it's not it's not
threatening all that much
maybe Queen to e6 immediately trading
but okay this is a bit more interesting
I also still have rookie three on the
agenda if I get a queen and not against
Queen and Bishop I maybe have some
chances even
No as the widest super-solid backwards
No and it would actually take
h5 there's going to be Queen III I guess
no don't want dad yeah okay I can try
maybe two oh it's okay it's not going to
take him just queen of Tours better
no it's taking interesting I thought
this would just be better for lucky I
mean I basically am a poor knob
now the force coming just a moment is it
better even to play Knight h5 here king
of true can i address deerforce good he
cannot even a you cannot do that
actually had blundered upon now and that
was the second threat yeah name in black
maybe you can win this sometimes it is
notoriously solid but he made I think
some some awkward decisions are with the
trades this line I recommended c4 in my
book this line I think in general is
quite okay from like a bit wide risky
for this I think is what what will
happen where black has active pieces and
white has still a slightly better pawn
structure it's not it's not better for
for for any side I think so was he three
I went back should be five rupee age I
don't think that there are many things
going on so yeah this maybe I should go
g5 the engine is pretty much in favor of
this I didn't really appreciate Queen d6
but that makes a lot of sense
and this I just go back right no Bishop
takes uh of course yeah I can take this
this is really strong with the huge game
for black something like that looks
terrible
oh man okay so g5 was strong now I am I
took only two and I should play g5
probably straight away and then c5 yeah
I should
this is true we I'm what the engine
gives you is essentially almost the game
just make sure that it happens say after
c6 white maybe has some alternatives
I would not much actually
yeah Queen d6 is stronger than the check
check is just parts of C's check gifts
check I mean I'm a little bit more
comfortable here because of the better
structure and the white bishop is an odd
piece it's actually pretty bad piece
because it's not attacking anything but
I don't think yeah okay Group III is
stronger average I wanted to just point
out one thing this is helping me that
trade and now we definitely shouldn't
trade Queens there's just a big no-no
don't try to impotent Red Queen's I was
expecting Queen f2 and I don't really
think I got much I can't go Queen d6 and
then we continue I mean I don't think
I'm better if anybody I can try it a
little bit but I think it's it's not not
of any significance but this is now
giving me a huge advantage really I'm
basically a pawn up and I got the better
structure I mean this is just like the
double pawn is just like one down
in mind my pawns are either on dark
squares one can get them and that is
just cash is awful
yeah I mean it went down it very quickly
but I think the the ending here after
the Queen trade is extremely bad and the
engine is giving black a winner already
right white has no idea I'm basically a
pawn up and I have an easy game okay
guys thanks for watching